the ending of The Martian the 2015 movie
based on the book by Andy Weir commits
so many crimes against scientific
accuracy that it almost ruins the rest
of the movie that is a fairly
controversial statement considering that
the Martian is widely praised as being
one of the most scientifically accurate
science fiction films ever made without
melting your brain like Interstellar did
and honestly it's great I love this
movie the level of scientific detail in
it is astounding most scientific
inaccuracies like Watney walking around
on Mars as if it's got Earth gravity and
subsequently Matt demon being ripped
enough for this gratuitous shirtless
scene these can mostly be explained Away
by practicalities of filming but the
ending the ending commits potentially
the worst crime that any movie claiming
scientific accuracy can commit it drives
an astrophysicists like me to make a
video like this picking it apart from
being completely and utterly ludicrous
the ending of The Martian centers on the
rescue of Mark Watney who has been
stranded on Mars for 549 Souls or to put
it in Earth time 564 days Watney has
already launched into space from the
surface of Mars and not much more than a
tent with a rocket on the back suffice
to say issues ensue and he doesn't make
it as high as intended he's too far from
the Hermes where his crew are waiting to
rescue him and they're traveling at
wildly different speeds to rescue botany
the crew build a bomb blow up their
front hanger causing an explosive
decompression of most of their living
species to slow down the Hermes which
solves most of the speed issue according
to the crew but not the distance issue
there's still some 312 meters between
Mark Watney and Commander Lewis what
Watney decides to do is cut a hole in
his glove and fly like Iron Man using
the thrust from the escaping air from
his glove to propel him towards
Commander Lewis and ultimate rescue this
whole rescue attempt has so many issues
that I'm gonna have to go bit by bit
also I'm not Simon if you haven't
noticed already my name is Thomas rental
I am an astrophysics Master student and
science Communicator who Simon's
greatest invited to make a video for his
channel there are a few differences
between myself and the weatherman for
one thing I'm Scottish for another I'm
not over six feet tall but there's more
about me at the end of the video for now
let's let physics that is real physics
not movie physics explain what really
should have happened at the end of The
Martian if we're gonna ignore the whole
going into space on gratar the Martian
atmosphere is essentially non-existent
it's very very thin so you don't get the
same levels of burnout per atmospheric
friction that you get with Earth's
atmosphere this brings us on to the
speed difference between Mark Watney and
the Hermes this is indeed a problem they
need to essentially match speeds at
least to the point that somebody could
catch water to stop him flying off into
space otherwise this rescue attempt is
never going to happen anyone who's
played a bit of Kerbal Space Program or
done things properly and studied orbital
mechanics we'll know that a bit of
thrust in the right direction is what's
needed the Hermes crew need to slow down
the Hermes to Rendezvous with Watney but
because the Hermes only has low thrust
but highly efficient ion thrusters they
can't use those to change speed fast
enough to rescue Mark Whitney if you
want to learn more about ion thrusters
then check out Simon's recent PhD
stories video where he talks to someone
researching the technology since the
thrusters are out of the question the
Hermes crew decided to slow down by
venting atmosphere in one of the most
ridiculous ways possible
the explosion wouldn't make it any
better of us of a slowing mechanism
there's nothing for it to push against
you would get the same thrust from just
opening the door and venting the
atmosphere that way I know in the book
they say that they can't just attack the
Hermes and open the door but they could
hack it before so I'm sure they could
hack it now it's really dumb I know it's
in the book but a bomb should not have
been plan a but explosive decompression
isn't the biggest issue with this whole
rescue attempt the biggest issue in my
opinion is thrust vectoring and
specifically mark watney's insistence on
flying like Iron Man I'd get to fly
around like Iron Man this in particular
annoys me because the movie even tries
to take it into account first you have
this line from Commander Lewis I can't
see you have any control if you did that
you'd be eyeballing The Intercept using
a Thrust Vector you can barely control
and then when Whitney does cut a hole in
his glove he flies around inside the
spacecraft you know like this
so they tried to show it why am I taking
issue with this I'm taking issue with
this because about five seconds later
they completely ignore it arm outstretch
managing to control this thrust vector
and going in a straight line this is an
issue because of what thrust vectoring
is thrust vectoring is the physical
principle that the location of a force
relative to a body's Center of mass
affects how that Force acts on the body
affects what it does if Watney had
instead cut a hole in the bottom of his
basement rather than in the glove then
air would be escaping approximately
below his Center of mass this would be
like putting a rocket underneath a
spaceship all that thrust going straight
through the center of mass and sending
you off in a straight line but the hole
is Not underneath Mark Wally the hole is
in the glove of his spacesuit this is
held outstretched away from his Center
of mass so it's going to cause more
rotational motion than linear motion
this is what we see initially when he
cuts a hole in the glove you see him
spinning around however the movie just
expects you to completely forget about
that seconds later when Mark Bonnie is
flying like Iron Man over to Commander
Lewis in her spacesuit with her jetpack
what should have been happening here
wasn't Mark watney's rescue but rather
his human-sized centrifuge experiment as
he builds up a rotation from the era
escaping from his outstretched glove but
fine let's suspend our disbelief a
little bit more and assume that Mark
Watney is some kind of superhero that
can get this thrust Vector under control
to be pointing the right direction to
send him off on his merry way to
Commander Lewis would the thrust from
his glove even have saved him no not a
chance physics once again not on his
side we're gonna assume that NASA's
technical specs have not changed between
now and 2035 so Mark's spacesuit is
going to be sitting at about 4.3 pounds
per square inch of atmospheric pressure
which is about one-third of the
atmospheric pressure at sea level the
reason it can be so low is because they
don't put nitrogen into the suits they
just put oxygen straight in because you
you still want to be able to move around
if it was held at our sea level
atmospheric pressure it'd be like being
in a massive balloon and they couldn't
do anything we're going to assume that
Mark Martin's suit is able to maintain
this pressure of 4.3 pounds per square
inch throughout his flight replacing any
Oxygen loss to space with oxygen from a
reserve tank great how big a hole is he
reasonably going to be able to make
it's probably only going to manage about
a square centimeter that's not very much
area so how much thrust can he
reasonably expect to be able to get from
his tiny little oxygen gas Thruster
extended out on his glove it's not going
to be very much the force from the
escaping gas comes from a pressure
gradient a difference in pressure
between the one-third of sea level
atmospheric pressure inside the suits
and the complete lack of pressure in the
vacuum of space and while there is
enough air in the spacesuit to breathe
oxygen is a fairly light gas with a
density of only around 0.4 kilograms per
cubic meter of volume inside the
spacesuit there's not much mass there so
even though each oxygen molecule is
escaping at incredible speed the force
they provide is pretty pitiful
converting our NASA spec pressure back
from Freedom Units to the metric system
that pressure over the one centimeter
squared hole in Mark's glove is only
going to give him around 0.15 meters per
second per second of acceleration
towards the Hermes with that minuscule
level of acceleration it it would take
Mark Watney over an hour to cover the
312 meters between the Mars Ascent
vehicle and the Hermes with the relative
velocities when he sets off of about 11
or 12 meters per second the Hermes is
going to be long gone by the time Mark
has any chance of getting to their
position flying like Iron Man
was never ever going to work so what
would have happened to Mark Watney after
he poked a hole in his glove assuming
that his skin wasn't pulled into the
hole plugging it like we've seen with a
real life space suit print trees chances
are he would just build up a slow
rotation inside the map while he first
tries to get it under control assuming
he can manage that he'd get a small
linear motion towards the Hermes
building up a very slow amount of speed
ultimately we've established that would
never get him there eventually likely
hundreds of meters away from the MAV his
oxygen would run out and he would drift
off into space forever the Hermes having
to return to Earth with the many
months-long trip again one crew member
down so how did Andy we are author of
The Martian the book not the movie get
this so spectacularly wrong in an
otherwise really scientifically accurate
story spoiler alert if you care at this
point he didn't he completely dismissed
all of this nonsense in the book
hey what he said over the radio I've got
an idea of course you do Lewis said what
do you got I could find something sharp
in here and poke a hole in the glove for
my Eva suit I could use the escaping air
as a Thruster and fly my way to you the
source of thrust would be on my arm so
I'd be able to direct it pretty easily
how does he come up with this Martinez
interjected you'd be eyeballing the
intercept and using a Thrust vector and
you can barely control I admit it's
fatally dangerous what he said but
consider this I'd get to fly around like
Iron Man Iron Man Commander Iron Man
Commander Lewis completely disregards
this whole ludicrous idea from the
offset the Hermes crew then uses a
combination of using the attitude
control thrusters and blowing up the
valve yes they use the bomb in the book
it's still dumb but desperate times I
guess in the book this works they don't
need the whole flying like Iron Man
section and the whole thing is far more
scientifically accurate so is the ending
of The Martian scientifically accurate
No with the ending from the book have
been quite as good a spectacle for
removing of course not am I still mad
about it well yeah but I'm a parent with
an astrophysics degree so I guess I'm
just going to get used to it thank you
very much for watching my video all the
way to the end thank you to look for
editing it for me and particularly thank
you to Simon for giving me the
opportunity to share a video on his
platform I just really wish it was under
better circumstances if you enjoyed this
video then please do come and subscribe
to my YouTube channel there'll be a link
in the video description below as well
as a button somewhere around here for
you to do just that I am currently
finishing off my master's degree in
astrophysics at the University of Saint
Andrews and I will hopefully someday
soon be embarking on a PhD
I make videos like this one to make
physics and particularly astronomy
accessible and entertaining and quite
early in my YouTube Journey so it would
be really good to have as many of you
along for the ride as possible I also
stream pretty regularly over on Twitch I
post on Instagram and I scream into the
void on Twitter those all have varying
levels of science as part of them the
handles for those will be on the screen
and in the video description below if
you want to come and check those out in
the meantime all I have left to say is
thank you very much again for watching
the video like comment subscribe to
Simon subscribe to me and I will see you
in the next video over on my channel see
ya